the police presence is deceptively calm
given the severity of the attacks
two men went on a stabbing spree in a
remote indigenous community in southern
canada
today september 4th at 5 40 this morning
the saskatchewan divisional operations
communication center
or the rcmp docc
received a call reporting a stabbing
on the james smith cree nation
in the following minutes our docc
received multiple calls
reporting additional stabbings at
different locations in the community
the suspects named were damien sanderson
and miles sanderson pictures of the two
suspects have been circulating
nationwide
as the investigation confirmed the two
suspects damien sanderson and miles
sanderson were traveling in a vehicle
at 9 45 a.m a fourth dangerous persons
alert was sent to the entire province
indicating multiple victims in multiple
locations were located prime minister
justin trudeau has tweeted the attacks
in saskatchewan are horrific and
heartbreaking i'm thinking of those who
have lost a loved one and of those who
were injured
checkpoints have been set up across the
region the manhunt continues
stephanie decker al-jazeera